and I think I know hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to
pillage the village now a long time ago
I played this game called defend your
castle and a lot of you guys probably
played it too and it was made by the
studio called x-gen Studios who made a
bunch of really awesome flash games and
I've never played this one before and I
saw you guys recommending it so I had to
check it out and oh boy it is a moral
like dilemma or not even a moral dilemma
it's a moral travesty because basically
what you do is you take your little hand
here you grab these little guys
you're shaking around how do you where's
my money where my money where my money
and then you smash them on the ground
and then you take their money not
exactly happy but it's a game and oh man
oh man it gets worse from there oh boy
do you think that was bad just a guy
trying to camp out in the woods now you
go to their home and you say they're
family huh fee fie foe fum give me your
[ __ ] money give me your money ma'am
you should have stayed hiding down below
oh no you wanted to see what happened to
your family member do bad boy up sorry
buddy poink oh man it's just like whoa
this game is villagers pillaged you mean
villagers mert alized and then robbed of
their possessions because that's pretty
much it and in the first game that I was
talking about a defender Castle it's a
base same basic principle except it's
stick figures coming at your castle
trying to get revenge on the horrible
things that you've done I am don't get
what you think you can run away you
think you can just run away you
defenseless villagers now I want all
your money you gonna come out what boink
sorry about that
what boink well man I don't know I don't
know this one because why me not a
a fun game like I gotta admit like as
horrible as it is and sometimes these
horrible games was fun for some strange
reason and it's fun because the basic
concept of the game
is good oh boy
an upgrade shop pacifist and - oh I
didn't know about this oh god I could go
the pacifist route or I could go the
antagonist route ooh
choices choices choices what a slave
cage doesn't exactly seem like the
pacifist route you don't have the heart
to hurl defenseless villagers into the
ground do the right thing instead offer
them a permanent job working in your
voluntary coal mine seem happy
antagonists oh boy simply whoa oh whoa
what about neutral how about neutral
I'll go neutral for now ah life
insurance pause okay I can't buy any of
these right now so I'm just gonna
continue with what I got and we'll go
from there so let's get to it
I wonder if there's like separate
endings for pacifists and anarchists oh
man hey what are you doing in your in
your nice tracksuit lovely oh you're
tough oh he's got a he's got a pursuit
oh that's right oh jeez oh that's not
good huh hey oh I thought if you threw
them high enough they would just end up
landing and you know Chris platting war
they do they do the answer is that they
do goodbye sir
oh gee oh geez oh geez Oh horrible Oh
what happened to that guy hat boink hep
hep boink good point something happened
to that guy in the distance over there
just his arm and leg was all that was
remaining from his horrible travesty
that befell him what is this horrible
deity that I am okay
euthanasia Oh God oh man oh man
I'll just go the antagonist route
because passive it just seems like an
excuse antagonists at least you know
what you're doing alright let's go that
route and the worst thing is I have a
funny feeling dude I'm not gonna feel
bad yeah [ __ ] sorry buddy oh sorry sorry
sorry sorry
sandbox mode unlocked so you can kill
with reckless abandon feel no guilt for
you there's another weird floating arm
and leg hip boink boink yep I was 100%
right
I don't feel nearly as bad wall my god
how did they are we done great can I go
home now oh I am home great okay good
for me good for me oh man man a power
plant oh all right I'm gonna try to use
my power gauntlet next time you know cuz
I don't think I was doing nearly good
enough in the previous round so I gotta
make sure that death befall everybody
possible okay how do I it's like a
spells oh there we go yeah oh Jesus
aw gee Scoob whoa gee Scoob oh my god i
crippled him oh geez oh god he was
crawling for his life oh man oh man oh
this ain't good
oh this is the opposite of good hello
boy this is the type of game that I
would play like as a kid in
cool just like I'm obviously putting too
much thought into it it's just a game
obviously all brutality bonus yeah is
there such a thing as a pacifist bonus -
to mean oh that's like my alignment is
getting more brutal as time goes on
Who am I to complain about it I'm
choosing this so yes all right yeah I
guess okay oh jeez
boink hop in a blank boink boink D Happ
no get that give me Pam Oh
boink blam boink boink blam
you you blam oh geez Wow sorry Hey look
huh oh jeez
Hey look oh oh jeez hey look I'm out of
mana you're lucky
well not really it still got smashed
into the ground oh geez oh geez
hello welcome to the party huh boom man
what kind of greedy Danny is just
smashing up villagers you know you could
ask I guess he could demand taxes I mean
if a giant floating and is trying his
best to go for these people then you
know it's gonna be bad and you know what
you know what I'm actually gonna cuz I
don't think I'm gonna do a full
playthrough this I'm gonna show you
defend your castle I'm gonna show you
the other game that's a part of this if
I can find it alright so defend your
castle came out before that other game
and when this game was playing through
it didn't seem nearly as bad because
number one stick figures and one of
hurts stick figures involved it doesn't
seem so bad for some [ __ ] reason I
don't know why but also it seemed like
they were the antagonist but now it's
even more cruel knowing that somehow
someway you were the cause of all this
goodbye oh jeez oh and the sound effects
are just so stock but oh so stock but
brutal like like you killed god damn it
honey okay I just got a drop
from high enough throwing uh missing the
mechanic in this one you just got to
drop them up grip or toss them up
whatever way you want to do it it's
still bad yeah I survived so oh yeah
there are upgrades in this ones too you
build a temple for them to worship you
in sore wrists does this mean Oh
so yeah that's defend your castle I'll
play one more round but not much more
than that I don't know how much my heart
can take because at the end you the
casualties start climbing because you
get like you get like bonus dudes on
your parapets over here and they help
you murder even more which is always
good and then you start flinging up with
reckless abandon and then you get like
slowed down and you can't kill them fast
enough and there's free of murdering
until your soul leaves your body and you
never feel any feelings ever again
anyway that's all the game is so that's
probably all I'm gonna play for now
thank you guys for being so patient I'm
sorry these videos have been late
yesterday I was filming up with Matthias
and I filmed like we recorded I recorded
a bunch of Let's Plays and also we
recorded eight challenge videos walls up
there so those are gonna start coming
out pretty soon I'm pretty sure like
every Friday from now on we're gonna be
doing those and thank you for the
patience this morning I got up I was so
tired and then I spilled coffee all over
my keyboard and I had to go out and get
a new keyboard and now I'm here and it's
late blah blah blah I'm an [ __ ] but
thank you guys for being so patient
there will be another video today so
don't worry about that I'll be working
on it right after this one so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
just gloss by that one